société il y aura peut-être bientôt des
distributeurs de préservatifs dans tous
les lycées de france afin de favoriser
la lutte contre le sida
le secrétaire d'état aux droits de la
femme véronique meyer s'est déclaré
aujourd'hui favorables à l'installation
de ses distributeurs dans tous les lieux
publics le ministre participait
également aux états généraux de la
contraception organisé par le planning
familial réunion au cours de laquelle
les associations n'ont pas caché leur
inquiétude face au manque de moyens dont
se révèle notamment victimes les centres
d'interruption volontaire de grossesse
autorise